James Comey says he believes that he was
fired because the investigation of
Russian election meddling was putting
pressure on the president Nancy Cordes
was in the hearing room for a commis
public testimony Nancy good morning good
morning committee aides see commies
testimony as a turning point in this
investigation they think it will compel
other top current and former
administration officials to meet with
the committee as well what left senators
really scratching their heads were the
number of times that Comey said that the
president lied to him or to the public
and pressured him about the
investigation I think there are a lot of
questions that remain to be answered and
I have hundreds of outstanding concerns
I like getting all the evidence before
I've made the decision
commis for our hearing left senators
with a lot to mull over was unmistakable
from Jim Comey's testimony today that
President Trump engaged in inappropriate
and unethical behavior some Republicans
argued unethical is a lot different than
unlawful whether it rises to criminality
you know I think there's significant
doubts about what it rises to that level
call me described for senators why he
decided to keep memos about his
one-on-one meetings with the president I
was honestly concerned that he might lie
about the nature of our meeting and so I
thought it really important to document
he said mr. Trump asked him in the Oval
Office to drop the FBI investigation
involving former national security
adviser Michael Flynn why didn't you
stop and say mr. president this is wrong
I cannot discuss this with you it's a
great question
maybe if I were stronger I would have I
was so stunned by the conversation that
I just took it in do you sense that the
president was trying to obstruct justice
I don't think it's for me to say whether
the conversation I have with the
president was an effort to obstruct I
took it as a very disturbing thing very
concerning Comey said that after he was
fired the president disparaged him and
the FBI so he shared his memos with a
friend a Colombian law professor asking
him to pass them along to the press so
why didn't you give those to somebody
yourself rather than give them through a
third party cuz I was worried the media
was camping at the end of my driveway at
that point I were
it would be like feeding seagulls at the
beach if if it was if it was I who gave
it to the media so I asked my friend
make sure this gets out so what's next
well committee leaders are hoping to
meet with the new Special Counsel robert
muller as early as next week and
committee staff are going to be
conducting a preliminary interview with
White House senior advisor Jared Kushner
Norah all right Nancy thank you so much